ever sets the pandemic transport for
London has been running in the red they
desperately need more money that's what
an awful lot of this anti-car stuff is
about because councils as well they're
getting less money from central
government so they need Josh and they
are reaming the motorists as viciously
as they know how
and if you add that to a cost of living
crisis in the highest taxes in 70 years
and
you know you just feel persecuted and I
think quite just Lisa and I think this
is a huge political mistake grits are
pretty
tolerant they take a lot of abuse far
more than most nationalities certainly
not like the French but you can push
even a Brit see it far